dans la campagne du Dombas nous avons
rendez-vous avec l'élite des artilleurs
Ukrainiens
concentration extrême et commandant aux
Agay cette unité utilise les fameux
canon César livrés par la France
ça va aller très vite soyez prêt
voici les Césars
trois canons français au cœur de la
bataille du Dombas
alignement dans ce champ de colza
préparation au tir
procédure millimétrée et obus de 155 mm
la cible aujourd'hui
des pièces d'artillerie russe
positionnées à 17 km
ce sont très sourds écoutez bien
c'est l'arrivée des obus sur les
objectifs visés
seulement 4 minutes et 20 secondes dans
ce champ puis c'est déjà le départ nous
repartons vers une base militaire que
nous nous filmons pas cette brigade
c'est la cible à abattre aux yeux des
Russes
dans cette pièce un officier fait les
comptes
images dans l'appui après chaque tir de
César des drones de surveillance
ukrainien survolent les cibles visées
ici des chars russes détruits il y a
quelques jours et des corps de nombreux
soldats ennemis
ce jour-là
que nous avons visé essayer de se
disperser de se cacher sous les arbres
ce commandant a si César à sa
disposition selon lui ils ont permis
l'élimination d'au moins 80 pièces
d'artillerie russe ces jeunes artilleurs
ukrainiens ont été formés en France en
pleine guerre il y a un mois sur une
base militaire dans le sud de l'Hexagone
pour étudier la technique de tir du
César
on a reçu beaucoup d'informations on a
dû tout comprendre le plus vite possible
en moins de deux semaines
maîtriser par exemple le système
d'entrée des coordonnées de la cible
le César c'est la fierté de l'artillerie
française
après avoir été utilisé ces César
français sont conduits dans des endroits
du don-basse tenu totalement secret il
ne roule jamais sur les routes de jour
il roule la nuit dans des champs comme
celui-ci